don't change that channel wand of vision
is continuing to reinvent the wheel for
the marvel cinematic universe
taking the reality warping series into a
1990s pastiche
keep watching to check out everything
you might have missed in episode six
wandavision's sixth episode all new
halloween spooktacular
takes a leap over the 90s to deposit us
in the early aughts
with its faux home video camera work and
pop punk theme
the intro to episode 6 echoes the intro
to the sitcom malcolm in the middle
which premiered in early 2000
and concluded in 2006. the intro song
includes lyrics reflecting the bizarre
events in west view
like don't try to fight the chaos and
later what if it's all an illusion
amusingly the actual theme song to
malcolm in the middle with its you're
not the boss of me now refrain
also feels like it would be suitable for
wanda's reality warping rebellion
like malcolm often did with its title
character episode 6 begins with billy
narrating
though his inner dialogue doesn't last
past the first scene
young avengers fans are no doubt hoping
that billy and his brother tommy will
eventually grow to become their super
powered comic book counterparts
in the comics billy is wiccan a mystical
hero
and one of the founding members of the
young avengers meanwhile tommy is like
quicksilver
a mutant with the gift of super speed
whose code name is
creatively speed whether or not billy
and tommy appear in the mcu
after one division fans can at least say
they got a chance to see them use their
powers and dress in there
for the most part comic book accurate
costumes
billy's costume which he wears
throughout the episode is wiccan's
costume in the comics
pietro gives tommy a smaller version of
his own costume
which is not what speed wears in the
comics but it's still fitting
considering his powers you may also
notice that just before pietro starts
wreaking havoc in the suburban
neighborhood with his nephews
he and tommy share a top gun reference
episode 6 gives us some scenes between
pietro and wanda after the bombshell
cameo at the end of episode
5. and unsurprisingly there are a lot of
obvious callbacks to 2015's avengers age
of ultron
sokovia is mentioned a few times
including wanda saying her outfit
is a sokovian fortune teller and the
quick flashback to the young wanda and
pietro
trick-or-treating in their homeland
wanda mentions their childhood growing
up in an orphanage together
and after she calls pietro a bad
influence the brother fires back
who beefed in your borscht with borscht
being from the same region of europe
where you would find zakovia
if it were a real place right after that
exchange the twins both ask each other
about the disappearances of their
accents
something wanda slips back into briefly
in the previous episode and of course
there are references to pietro's death
early in the episode tommy teases billy
saying that his twin is afraid that
pietro is a vampire
a creature who possibly like pietro is
neither dead nor alive
you get killed walk it off
at the town square scare pietro tells
his sister he remembers being
shot like a chump and later she has a
brief vision of him pale
and riddled with bullet holes you didn't
see that coming
[Music]
one thing worth noting is that pietro
says he was shot like a chump for no
reason at all
when in fact in age of ultron he
sacrifices himself in order to save
hawkeye
and a sokovian boy which seems like a
pretty worthy cause to us
all new halloween spooktacular finally
gives us
wanda and vision in their old school
marvel comic book getups
images of the pair in their half-baked
costumes were some of the first photos
released for the series
billy appropriately thinks his mother is
dressed as old red riding hood
while pietro compares vision to a
traffic light a half-shocked corn cob
and a booger and he's what you call a
man-child
after pietro suggests he joined wanda
and the boys for halloween
wanda says he doesn't have a costume
prompting pietro to use his super speed
to put himself and tommy in matching
outfits reflecting what quicksilver used
to wear in marvel's comics
the silver lightning bolt is straight
from the funny books as
is the slicked back wolverine style hair
does it look good in real life
well not really but it's still a pretty
neat thing to finally see
some fans are understandably hopeful
that evan peter's presence in
wandavision could be the beginning of
the entrance of the x-men into the mcu
while it's far too soon to say whether
this is the case episode 6 has a couple
of x-men references early in the story
as the couple argue about whether or not
vision will be trick-or-treating with
wanda and the boys
pietro steps in to take the synthezoid's
place
big guy is a conflict twins need a
father figure for the night
don't sweat it sis i got the old xy
chromosome
weird line right for pietro to mention
his dna
and the letter x is a pretty obvious
reference to the team professor x built
there's another x-men reference that's
just a bit easier to miss a few moments
later
the neighborhood watch is the only thing
that stands between the trees and the
toilet paper
as vision says his line he points in
opposite directions and his forearms
cross
to form a big yellow x
the ad for all new halloween
spooktacular is perhaps the most bizarre
faux commercial we've seen yet on
wandavision
the ad uses stop motion animation and
shows us a boy
stuck on an island in the middle of the
ocean a talking shark drops in with a
surfboard
gives the boy a yo magic yogurt snack
and leaves the boy can't seem to open
the container and his teeth clatter as
if he's freezing even though the sun
seems to be faking him
time speeds up and he keeps trying and
failing to open the yo magic snack
eventually he withers away to a skeleton
the ad ends with a shot of the yo magic
packaging
and the slogan yo magic the snack for
survivors
the ad seems to be a fusion of at least
a couple of different brands of similar
snacks from the 90s in early aughts
the packaging is reminiscent of
yoplait's gogurt while the ad itself
pulls heavily from yogo yogurt
which used stop motion in its ads as for
magic being essential for survival
the message seems obvious at the town
square scare
a movie marquee gives us a couple more
easter eggs
and like many of the other references
there's a bit of a time gap between them
westview's coronet theater is showing
two films
on screen one is the incredibles which
came out in 2004.
it's a fitting movie reference
considering by the end of episode six
every member of wanda and vision's
family has superpowers
in fact only moments after we see the
marquee tommy discovers his super speed
screen 2 is showing the parent trap
however
which assuming we're talking about the
remake and not the original from 1961
came out six years before the
incredibles in 1998
either way both versions of the film
feature a pair of twins
separated at birth it's an after
reference considering how pietro and
wanda have been separated since the
farmer's death and how
in the comics at least billy and tommy
were long-lost twins themselves
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one